pensant l'a dit donc on va vous faire
une interview rois de france
bien si vous étiez roanne france qui
serait votre reine mon épouse à qui
serait votre favorite
mon épouse votre épouse m'a sérieusement
après les deux rôles elle frères et mes
favoris louis adacore qui serait votre
richelieu bien je vais vous dire est à
le premier ministre c'est vrai que les
français qui vont le choisir
et oui puisque c'est une royauté
constitutionnel est d'accord il y aura
des élections et et il y aura donc à la
liste
c'est réglé pas mal à montréal et
sérieux donc ça se fait en angleterre
c'est de l'air on estime t elle
le chef du parti qui gagne les élections
ça serait votre premier ministre alors
vous habiteriez versailles ou le château
de la star ac' monseigneur non non ni
l'un ni l'autre
vous n'avez pas le château de la star ac
je vais vous dire si imaginons près
pourquoi faire des dépenses inutiles
versailles c'est tout le blé longue non
l'elysée est meublé l'elysée avait
mesuré à l'elysée maillard il ya toute
la machinerie
ouais le bouton pour la bombe atomique
est-ce que vous remplacerez la
marseillaise si vous étiez roi de france
monseigneur non ah non parce que la
musique est très belle et ne change rien
les paroles quand même je demanderai je
ferai un référendum et une mauvais tour
au français l'huile génial l'attendait
c'est énorme ça vous allez faire que
demander aux français vous je viens de
faire travailler
c'est ça les rois en même temps c'est la
démocratie a dit moi avons signé en
feriez quoi des grimaldi là si vous
étiez roi de france qui rage sur leur
rocher
ouais vous seriez pour un rapprochement
avec leroy merlin
là j'ai une question bon seigneur vous
feriez quoi si vous étiez roi de france
pour éviter la révolution eh bien je
ferai
nous demanderons aux français de voter
non de faire des cahiers de doléances à
un cahier et après tu coupes la tête qui
fait les choses non parce que vous
couriez la clim si vous étiez l'histoire
est évité
c'est bien